so in this video I want to talk a little
bit about enzymes regulation and it's
very very important understand enzyme
regulation just because we're gonna talk
about a lot of different enzymes and a
lot of different pathways including that
causes the TCA cycle and and others and
so we need to understand how enzymes
enzymes are regulated so there are
particular ways to enzyme to regulate
enzyme activity and it's also important
to kind of keep in mind how should we
know if an enzyme is going to be
regulated what kind of which enzymes
would be regulated right that's what
that's what we want to keep in mind and
consider and be able to think about so
one of the ways there are different
levels of regulation for instance if
there's a particular enzyme that you
should remember that enzymes are
proteins right and proteins come if you
recall the central dogma they come
basically from DNA DNA is transcribed
into mRNA and mrna is then translated
into protein to proteins so how much of
a protein or an enzyme is you know that
is made can be regulated based on you
know how much of it is actually
transcribed how much of that emanate
mRNA is process or how that mRNA is
processed how much of that is translated
or how is it translated and proteolysis
is proteolytic level sort of describes
the proteolysis to simply be the you
know breaking up of a protein so all of
these these are all at all these
different levels we can have regulation
of how much enzyme is even created okay
I'm not gonna talk too much about this
which is kind of why it's breezed over
it just now but I do want to talk about
this here so there are you know plenty
of ways to actually regulate protein
activity the three that I'm primarily
concerned with and that I want to
mention in this video are these three
the first one is allosteric control
which is something we've actually hinted
on in a previous video about hemoglobin
we mentioned Cooper cooperativity which
was a form of allosteric regulation or
allosteric control but there will be a
video arm specifically on allosteric
regulation later I also want to talk
about reversible covalent modification
it'll also have its own video that
includes a phosphorylation and
dephosphorylation
relation again I'll include that in the
later video
and of course it's last bit here the
irreversible covalent modification which
includes proteolytic activation again
that means the cutting up of a protein
once it's actually been translated so
that will also have its own video so now
I so all this all more on all this later
but let's talk about how you should know
how would we know if an enzyme is
regular or which enzymes would be expect
to be regulated or regulated highly and
let's think about this enzymes that
catalyze reactions that are pretty much
irreversible so if an if a reaction is
pretty much irreversible then it's going
to have a delta G that's large and
negative which sort of means that it is
a spontaneous or a very spontaneous
reaction right so if something's going
to be very very spontaneous the reverse
reaction would be very non spontaneous
would require a large input of energy so
if an enzyme is irreversible right then
we want to make sure that if that
reaction actually goes right that we
want to create that particular product
because if it's irreversible we can't
undo it right so basically the reasoning
behind this first thing here is the idea
that we would expect enzymes that
catalyze reactions that are irreversible
to be highly regulated because we want
to make sure that if there's a
particular irreversible step right that
creates a particular product we want to
make sure that that irreversible step
only happens when it needs to happen or
when it should happen because if we
can't reverse it that's a bad thing
right so we want to make sure that the
enzyme that catalyzes a reaction that is
irreversible is highly regulated so that
the reaction doesn't occur needlessly
the second thing is enzymes that that
catalyze reactions or catalyze the first
committed step in a metabolic pathway
what is this idea behind the first
committed step excuse me if you think
about it the the first committed step is
the first step that commits
to a particular pathway now I've drawn
out this this sort of idea here and to
kind of represent what I'm talking about
or what I want to talk about here so if
we think about each of these you know
ABCD all these different little things
here as being substrates and products of
particular reactions for instance a to b
is catalyzed by enzymes 1 b 2 c enzyme 2
and so on and so forth notice that once
we get to D here D can either go through
this path to create EF and G which is
this pathways end product this thing
here is an end product or D can go down
this pathway XY and Z and create Z which
is also an end product now these are two
different pathways so in essence D can
go to either E or do you can go to X so
both of these steps provide e going to e
once D has gone to e it has committed to
this pathway which has G as the end
product if it goes via B goes to X via
the enzyme cattle or the via the step
catalyzed by enzymes 7 then this is
going to commit to creating Z as an end
product so essentially we want to make
sure that that the steps that catalyze
the committed steps are the enzymes that
catalyze the committed steps are highly
regulated okay so that's kind of where
this where this gets that we don't want
to commit to a particular pathway unless
we want to create that particular end
product another thing I want to mention
is that as far as how that is sort of
regulated we would expect enzyme 4 and
enzyme 7 to be highly regulated because
they both catalyze first committed steps
right so we would expect enzyme 7 and
enzyme 4 to be regulated right
oftentimes the end product of a
particular pathway inhibits the enzyme
that catalyzes the first committed step
so in this case G is the end product of
this particular pathway this top pathway
here which enzyme number 4 catalyzes
that step that first committed step
here Z is the end product of this
pathway it would inhibit enzymes 7 so I
put this little negative sign here to
sort of indicate that that this these
end products would inhibit the first
step that commits to that pathway it
makes sense right because if if you
don't want to create if you have a lot
of G for instead of G's hanging around
these these G's you don't want to keep
creating more of them so the best way to
stop the production of them is to stop
the step that commits to creating G
right and the same thing here with Z if
there's a bunch of 0 and we want to stop
making it well the best way to do that
is to stop the the pathway from even
beginning to occur right so you would
inhibit these enzymes here which
catalyze the first come in to step in
those particular pathways the last thing
is that if there's an enzyme that
catalyzes a slow step in a pathway or
the rate determining step in a pathway
then because it determines the rate end
at which that reaction goes we want to
regulate that particular enzyme okay so
I want you to keep these three ideas in
mind but mostly these two mostly these
two are the most important ok it will be
will be mentioning that especially the
idea of a first committed step later
when we talk about glycolysis many of
you might already know what I'm getting
at here so these are the most important
at least in my opinion so I hope that
was helpful and sort of introducing you
to enzymes and how they're regulated so
thanks for watching